This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The first emperor of China was used to getting his way. By the time he was 40, Chinshuah Huangdi was the most powerful man in the world. During his reign some 2,000 years ago he united the warring nations of his kingdom. He standardized currency and weights and measures. He unified border walls into a single block that would eventually become the Great Wall of China. And so it seemed to this man who was larger than life, who had achieved so many things, that he could also conquer something no one had conquered before.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。中国的第一位皇帝习惯于随心所欲。到40岁时，秦始皇已是世界上最有权势的人。在他约2000年前的统治期间，他统一了国内的交战各国。他统一了货币、度量衡。他将边境的城墙连接成一个整体，最终形成了中国的长城。因此，对于这位超越凡俗、成就了如此多伟业的人来说，他似乎也认为自己可以征服前人从未征服过的东西。
Death. He went searching for an elixir that would give him eternal life. He travelled his kingdom, talking to wizards and alchemists and wise people and priests, and one day, and some distant part of his kingdom, he found a wise man who said, I know the recipe for an elixir. This is philosopher Stephen Kav. He says the wise man was a wizard named Shui Fu, and Shui Fu's offer to get the elixir came with a few conditions. You just have to get it from this distant island, and if you give me a ship fully equipped and loaded with virgins, I will be able to
死亡。他开始寻找能让他长生不老的灵丹妙药。他走遍全国，与巫师、炼金术士、智者和祭司交谈。有一天，在他王国的某个遥远角落，他遇到了一位智者，对方说：“我知道长生不老药的配方。”这位是哲学家斯蒂芬·凯夫。他说，那位智者是一位名叫徐福的方士，而徐福提出获取灵药的条件有几个。你只需要从那个遥远的岛屿上取回它，如果你给我一艘装备齐全、载满童男童女的船，我就能
go to this island and get the elixir of life for you. The Emperor was ecstatic. He gave Shui for the ship, the provisions, and the virgins. And then he carried on ruling over his great empire. When he came back to the wizard, a few years later, he found out that the virgins were no longer virgional, that the provisions had all gone, and he wondered where the Selixia was, and the wizard said, ah! Well, I tried to find the Selixia, but the closer we got to the island, the more sea
去那个岛上为你取回长生不老药。皇帝欣喜若狂。他给了徐福船只、补给和童男童女。然后他继续统治着他伟大的帝国。几年后，当他再次见到这位方士时，他发现那些童男童女已不再是处子之身，补给也已耗尽，他询问灵药在哪里，方士说：“啊！我确实试图寻找灵药，但我们越靠近那个岛屿，海里的
monsters rose up and defeated us, and so if you can only give us more virgins, more provisions, and a squadron of archers, well, I'll be able to get it for you. You might be able to guess what happened. The emperor gave him what he wanted, an offsuitful went, never to return to China. never to return to China. But what's a little interesting twist in this story is that around the same time there is a legend in Japan about a man who came from China with a boatload of provisions and soldiers, so I'm not sure if they mentioned the virgins, and to brought with him a great number of technologies like agriculture and
怪物就越多，它们击败了我们。所以，如果你能再给我更多的童男童女、更多的补给和一队弓箭手，我就能为你取回它。”你可能已经猜到发生了什么。皇帝给了他想要的一切，徐福便出发了，再也没有回到中国。再也没有回到中国。但这个故事中一个有趣的转折是，大约在同一时期，日本流传着一个传说，说有一个人从中国带着一船补给和士兵——我不确定他们是否提到了童男童女——并带来了大量的技术，如农业、
martial arts and building and many other things and that became the foundation of Japanese civilization. This story tells us two things. One, humans have been trying to cheat death for thousands of years and two, the hunger for immortality is inextricably linked to human culture. Almost everything we think of, these technologies of civilization like agriculture and martial arts and building and clothing and so forth, are, if you like, life extension technologies. And so I think it's unsurprising that at the heart of the promise, the founding promise of civilization, we find the promise of immortality.
武术、建筑以及许多其他事物，这些成为了日本文明的基础。这个故事告诉我们两件事。第一，人类几千年来一直试图战胜死亡；第二，对永生的渴望与人类文化有着千丝万缕的联系。我们所想到的一切，这些文明的技术，如农业、武术、建筑、服装等等，如果愿意的话，都可以看作是延长寿命的技术。因此，我认为在文明的承诺——即文明的创始承诺——的核心中，我们发现了永生的承诺，这并不令人惊讶。
This promise of immortality is a human response to a terrifying idea, the fact that one day we will die. Last week, we spoke with psychologists, children,on Solomon, about this fear and how it shapes our actions, often without us being aware of it. This week, we pivot from psychology and politics to religion and history as we explore the many ways people have tried to resolve their fears. The path to eternal life, today on Hidden Brain. Stephen Cave is the author of Immortality, the quest to live forever and how a drive civilization. Much of the book revolves around a philosophical conundrum that Stephen calls
这种永生的承诺是人类对一个可怕想法的回应，即我们终有一天会死去。上周，我们与心理学家谢尔登·所罗门讨论了这种恐惧以及它如何塑造我们的行为，通常是在我们毫无察觉的情况下。本周，我们将从心理学和政治学转向宗教和历史，探讨人们试图解决恐惧的多种方式。通往永生之路，今天在《隐藏的大脑》中。斯蒂芬·凯夫是《永生：追求长生不老与文明的驱动力》一书的作者。这本书的大部分内容围绕着一个斯蒂芬称之为
the mortality paradox. We know we will die, but can't really imagine being dead. It's impossible to imagine not existing. So if you think of trying to imagine being dead, you might imagine being in some other place, you might imagine looking down on your own funeral, but even just being in a void, all of these imaginings conjure a kind of observing eye, you're somehow still there as the observer. So imagining death becomes impossible, and that makes it very, very hard to truly believe that we will completely cease to exist. We are, if you like, innately prone to believe in our own immortality.
“死亡悖论”的哲学难题展开。我们知道自己会死，但却无法真正想象死亡的状态。想象自己不存在是不可能的。所以，如果你试图想象自己死亡，你可能会想象自己在某个其他地方，你可能会想象俯瞰自己的葬礼，但即使只是身处虚无之中，所有这些想象都会唤起一种观察者的视角，你不知何故仍然作为观察者存在。因此，想象死亡变得不可能，这使得我们很难真正相信自己会彻底消失。如果可以这样说，我们天生倾向于相信自己的永生。
And this, therefore, gives us our paradox. On the one hand, these enormous brains of ours tell us that mortality, that death, is inevitable. But at the same time, when we try to imagine being dead, we find it's impossible, and our brains reject it. You argue in the book that we find four distinct ways and have found these four distinct ways throughout human history to resolve this mortality paradox. You say we come up with these immortality narratives, four techniques that have been used in some ways to sort of bridge the divide of this paradox. I want to talk about them one by one. Look at some historical examples of how each of these narratives has been employed, how they're employed in contemporary times,
因此，这就产生了我们的悖论。一方面，我们巨大的大脑告诉我们，死亡是不可避免的。但与此同时，当我们试图想象死亡时，却发现这不可能，我们的大脑拒绝接受它。你在书中指出，在整个人类历史上，我们发现了四种截然不同的方式来解决这个死亡悖论。你说我们提出了这些永生叙事，即四种在某种程度上被用来弥合这一悖论鸿沟的技术。我想逐一讨论它们。看看每种叙事是如何被运用的历史例子，它们在当代是如何被运用的，
but also some of the potential problems with each of these mortality narratives. Tell me about the first one. That's right. Of course, the fear of death and the realization of death is universal. You find it in all human cultures. And in all human cultures, we find these stories and these strivings, these imaginings for how we can overcome death or avoid death. And even though there appears to be an enormous diversity of views, I think they actually fit into four basic broad categories. And the first of them, the most obvious, says, alright, we know life as this body, as this sort of human organism
以及每种死亡叙事的一些潜在问题。先告诉我第一个。没错。当然，对死亡的恐惧和对死亡的认识是普遍的。你在所有人类文化中都能找到它。在所有人类文化中，我们都能找到这些故事和追求，这些关于我们如何克服死亡或避免死亡的想象。尽管观点看起来多种多样，但我认为它们实际上可以归纳为四个基本的大类。其中第一个，也是最明显的，是说：好吧，我们知道生命就是这个身体，就是这个人类有机体，
on this world, the easiest and best way to stay alive forever is just not to die in the first place. So the simplest form of immortality belief is ready to just keep going forever. Now on the one hand, this might sound very implausible when we look at the extent to which death and disease and aging a part of everyday reality, yet at the same time almost every culture in human history has some kind of story of an elixir of life or a fountain of youth or something that can enable us to just keep going
在这个世界上，保持永生的最简单、最好的方法就是根本不要死。所以，最简单的永生信仰就是一直活下去。一方面，当我们看到死亡、疾病和衰老在日常现实中占据多大比例时，这听起来可能非常不可信，但与此同时，人类历史上几乎每一种文化都有某种关于长生不老药、青春之泉或某种能让我们在这个世界上永远保持这些身体活下去的故事。
in these bodies in this world forever. So these ideas have been explored at length in popular culture and movies. In the 1992 movie Death Becomes Her, Merrill Street plays a self-absorbed actress who wants to stay young and beautiful. So she visits a mysterious woman played by Isabella Rossellini,
所以这些想法在流行文化和电影中得到了广泛的探讨。在1992年的电影《飞越长生》中，梅丽尔·斯特里普饰演一位自恋的女演员，她想保持年轻和美丽。于是她拜访了一位由伊莎贝拉·罗西里尼饰演的神秘女子，
who offers her a glowing purple liquid. What is that? A tonic? A potion. What does it do? It stops the aging process dead in its tracks and forces it into retreat Drink that potion and you'll never grow even one day older Don't drink it and continue to watch yourself
她提供了一种发光的紫色液体。“那是什么？补药？药水。它有什么作用？它能让衰老过程彻底停止并迫使其退缩。喝下那瓶药水，你永远不会再老一天。不喝它，就继续看着自己……”
How much is it? What I love about this clip Stephen is how the how the story, the search for magic potions, it just comes back over and over again in different forms. Exactly. We want so desperately to believe this story. We find exactly the story in the very oldest story known to humankind, the epic of Gilgamesh, which is really the story of a man who realises when his friend dies that he himself is mortal and then goes on a great quest to find the solution and at one
“多少钱？”斯蒂芬，我喜欢这个片段的地方在于，这个故事，即对魔法药水的搜寻，在不同的形式中反复出现。正是如此。我们太渴望相信这个故事了。我们在人类已知的最古老的故事——《吉尔伽美什史诗》中发现了完全相同的故事，这实际上是一个人在朋友去世后意识到自己终有一死，然后踏上寻找解决方案的伟大征程的故事。在
point he finds a kind of elixir but he puts it down beside him to bathe in a pond and while he's bathing a snake steals it and the snake immediately sheds its skin and slithers off. Because this snake therefore rejuvenates in the way that we wish we could. And it's so tempting to think that we are the pinnacle of civilization and we are the ones who are enjoying all the fruits of science and technology. And therefore we are the generation
某个时刻，他找到了一种灵药，但他把它放在身边去池塘洗澡，在他洗澡时，一条蛇偷走了它，蛇立即蜕皮并溜走了。因为这条蛇以我们希望的方式恢复了活力。我们很容易认为自己是文明的巅峰，是享受科学和技术成果的人。因此，我们是那一代
who are really gonna crack it. The potions really, we read in the newspapers and we suck up those headlines that say, aging defeated, just eat blueberries and put this cream on your face. And of course, a few decades later, as our skin starts to wrinkle and crumple, we realize it was all just wishful thinking. Now, something extraordinary did happen in the course of the last 100 years. For really perhaps the first time in human history, you know, the length of human lifespan in many parts of the world doubled.
真正能破解它的人。我们阅读报纸，吸收那些标题，说“衰老已被战胜，只需吃蓝莓并把这种面霜涂在脸上”。当然，几十年后，当我们的皮肤开始起皱和松弛时，我们意识到这都只是痴心妄想。现在，在过去100年里，确实发生了一些非凡的事情。这可能是人类历史上第一次，你知道，在世界许多地方，人类的寿命翻了一番。
Vaccine, sanitation, antibiotics, all of these drove an increase in human longevity. And it really must have felt to many people that we had found a way to cheat death. I think that's exactly right. In a way we don't celebrate enough, this extraordinary revolution that is the doubling of life expectancy in the last couple hundred years in developed countries, from around 40 or so to the 80 years that many people in developed countries can enjoy today. Now, this revolution, this doubling of life expectancy, does lead some optimists to say, well, if we've doubled it once,
疫苗、卫生设施、抗生素，所有这些都推动了人类寿命的增长。对许多人来说，这一定感觉像是我们已经找到了战胜死亡的方法。我认为确实如此。在某种程度上，我们庆祝得不够，这种非凡的革命，即发达国家在过去几百年里预期寿命翻了一番，从大约40岁左右增加到今天许多发达国家人们可以享受的80岁。现在，这场革命，即预期寿命翻倍，确实导致一些乐观主义者说，好吧，如果我们已经翻了一次倍，
then we can double it again, and again, and again, indefinitely. But of course, when life expectancy was doubled the first time, we did it mostly by saving the lives of babies. So many of the interventions you mentioned, such as antibiotics and vaccinations and so forth, were about reducing child mortality. And of course, if you get people, if you get a baby through its first few years of life, get a child through its first five years of life,
那么我们就可以无限期地再次翻倍，再翻倍，再翻倍。但当然，当预期寿命第一次翻倍时，我们主要是通过挽救婴儿的生命来实现的。所以你提到的许多干预措施，如抗生素和疫苗等等，都是关于降低儿童死亡率的。当然，如果你能让一个人，如果你能让一个婴儿度过生命的最初几年，让一个孩子度过生命的最初五年，
then nature is on your side. Then you have someone who is likely, again, with a bit of medical support, going to live for 70 or 80 years. Now, of course, taking someone who 70 or 80 and getting them to live for another 70 or 80 years, as would be required by doubling life expectancy, again, is a completely different kind of challenge, and nature isn't on our side at all. So if endless rejuvenation is not a solution, that brings us to the second of your immortality narratives. What is it? So the second immortality narrative, I call
那么大自然就站在你这边。那么你就有了一个很可能在一点医疗支持下活到70或80岁的人。当然，让一个70或80岁的人再活70或80岁，正如预期寿命再次翻倍所要求的那样，是完全不同的一种挑战，而大自然根本就不站在我们这边。所以，如果无尽的返老还童不是解决方案，那这就引出了你的第二个永生叙事。它是什么？所以第二个永生叙事，我称之为
resurrection. And it's the second one in our logical sequence because it stays with the idea that we are these physical bodies, these physical organisms. And it says, okay, it looks like death is inevitable, or I mean, after all, the one thing that all these elixir seekers in the last few thousand years have in common is that they're all now six foot under, pushing up daisies. So if we're not going to find an elixir, we need a plan B. Staying with the idea that we are bodies, we might think, okay, these bodies do have to die, but maybe they can rise and live again. And this is something we see all around us in nature.
复活。这是我们逻辑序列中的第二个，因为它坚持认为我们是这些物理身体，这些物理有机体。它说，好吧，看起来死亡是不可避免的，或者说，毕竟，过去几千年来所有这些寻找灵药的人的共同点是，他们现在都已入土为安，长眠地下了。所以如果我们找不到灵药，我们需要一个B计划。坚持认为我们是身体，我们可能会想，好吧，这些身体确实必须死亡，但也许它们可以复活并再次生活。这是我们在大自然中随处可见的现象。
We see cycles of birth and death and then rebirth. And a lot of rituals in ancient religions are about taking the very linear progression of a human life from birth through growing in their aging and dying and transforming it into something more like this cyclical pattern of birth and death and rebirth, reappearing one day like the blue bows during spring. So what I like about this is that it has such intuitive appeal. Anyone who has a
我们看到出生、死亡，然后重生的循环。古代宗教中的许多仪式都是关于将人类从出生到成长、衰老和死亡的线性过程，转化为更像这种出生、死亡和重生的循环模式，就像春天里的花朵一样再次出现。所以我喜欢这一点，因为它具有如此直观的吸引力。任何拥有
garden looks out and sees that you know plans and shrubs that basically die out in the winter come back in the spring and it's so easy in some ways to make the intuitive leap that this must be possible for us to do as human beings as well. And the most famous example of this is a resurrection of Jesus. It's the story that's at the heart of Christianity. That's right. In the milieu in which the Jesus story emerged, obviously 2000 years ago, there were many legends of gods who went down to the underworld, or heroes or kings who went down to the underworld, and after some time there somehow managed to re-emerge, to be reborn. And these cults of rebirth were very closely associated with the seasons and with agriculture and was celebrated
花园的人向外看，都会看到那些在冬天基本枯萎的植物和灌木在春天又长了出来，在某种程度上，人们很容易直觉地跳跃到这种结论：作为人类，我们也一定能做到这一点。最著名的例子就是耶稣的复活。这是基督教核心的故事。没错。在耶稣故事出现的背景下，显然是2000年前，有许多关于神灵进入冥界，或者英雄或国王进入冥界，并在一段时间后以某种方式设法重新出现、重生的传说。这些重生的崇拜与季节和农业密切相关，并在
in spring and so forth. So it does seem deeply embedded in our psyche, the idea that there's a rhythm of rebirth that we can tap into. And of course that's what the Jesus story does in a very explicit way. By it builds on older Jewish stories of the promise of the resurrection of bones rising from the earth of the promise of the resurrection of bones rising from the earth, the version of the Jesus story that became so popular in the Roman empire and that we've inherited today is that Jesus died and was resurrected, he physically as a human organism rose from the grave. He ate fried fish in front of his followers to prove that he really was a living organism again.
春天等时候庆祝。所以，我们可以利用的重生节奏的想法似乎深深植根于我们的心理中。当然，这就是耶稣故事以一种非常明确的方式所做的事情。它建立在更古老的犹太故事之上，即复活的承诺，骨头从大地中升起的承诺，在罗马帝国变得如此流行并被我们今天继承的耶稣故事版本是：耶稣死了并复活了，他作为一个人类有机体从坟墓中物理地站了起来。他在追随者面前吃了炸鱼，以证明他确实又是一个活生生的有机体。
And the promise is that if we follow Jesus, that we too can rise physically from the grave and live again. It's a very explicit promise of immortality, which is enormously reassuring. And we find something like it in nearly all of the world religions. A very explicit promise of immortality can be found in Islam, for example, certainly forms of Judaism, including the orthodox, if you like, rabbinic Judaism, and we find something similar in Hinduism and Buddhism. So it seems a crucial part of the success story for a religion that it promised the defeat of death in some way. What one of the things that you mentioned in the book, of course, is that these narrative
而承诺是，如果我们追随耶稣，我们也能从坟墓中物理地站起来并再次生活。这是一个非常明确的永生承诺，非常令人安心。我们在几乎所有的世界宗教中都能找到类似的东西。例如，在伊斯兰教中可以找到非常明确的永生承诺，当然还有犹太教的形式，包括正统派，如果你愿意的话，拉比犹太教，我们在印度教和佛教中也发现了类似的东西。因此，承诺以某种方式战胜死亡似乎是宗教成功故事的关键部分。你在书中提到的事情之一，当然是这些叙事
surface over and over again, in our modern times, we also have a resurrection narrative. It doesn't involve Jesus rising from the dead. It involves science. That's right. Instead of the idea that an omnipotent God is going to raise us up from the graves, nowadays many people are much more inclined to believe in the omnipotence of science and technology. And so we see stories that very much parallel the older stories of resurrection being told into biomedical terms. So think of cryonics, for example. We all know that freezing things preserves them.
反复出现，在现代，我们也有一个复活叙事。它不涉及耶稣从死里复活。它涉及科学。没错。与其认为全能的上帝会让我们从坟墓中复活，如今许多人更倾向于相信科学和技术的全能。因此，我们看到那些与古老的复活故事非常平行的故事被用生物医学术语讲述。例如，想想人体冷冻技术。我们都知道冷冻东西可以保存它们。
Well, maybe we can preserve people when they die or are near death. So well, that one day we can for them out and repair whatever damage was done to them, whatever it was that was killing them. And we have people who are subscribing to cryonics, institutes, paying their life insurance, all their lives, so they can be put in a big silver pot when they die in liquid nitrogen in the hope that one day benevolent and omnipotent scientists will, will throw them out and fix them. Like the Rejuvenation narrative, the resurrection story has some serious philosophical holes. For one thing, which version of you is the one that gets revived? Is it the young you? Or the old and frail you?
好吧，也许我们可以在人们死亡或濒死时保存他们。这样有一天我们可以解冻他们，修复他们身上造成的任何损害，无论是什么导致了他们的死亡。我们有人在订阅人体冷冻机构，终身支付人寿保险，这样当他们死后，他们可以被放入一个巨大的银色罐子里，浸泡在液氮中，希望有一天仁慈且全能的科学家会解冻他们并修复他们。像返老还童叙事一样，复活故事也有一些严重的哲学漏洞。首先，复活的那个版本是你吗？是年轻的你？还是年老体弱的你？
Now imagine that I die and I'm riddled with cancer and very old and falling apart. And God or scientists resurrect me. They're somehow pumped life back into me. I climb out of the grave and I immediately fall back into it. Because I'm old and withered and full of cancer. Well, clearly no one wants to be resurrected as they were just as they died, because they would, necessarily, just die again.
现在想象我死了，我患有癌症，非常老，身体正在崩溃。上帝或科学家复活了我。他们以某种方式将生命注入我体内。我爬出坟墓，然后立即又倒了回去。因为我老态龙钟，满身癌症。好吧，显然没有人想以死时的样子复活，因为他们必然会再次死去。
They only have to be transformed in some way. They want to be rejuvenated and made immune to aging and disease, and usually it was a great long wish list of ways in which they'd like to change. And we see this in Christianity. St. Paul talks about being transformed into something immortal and durable, leaving behind of this sort of messy biological stuff. But if I'm to be transformed into something completely different, but it isn't messy biology,
他们必须以某种方式被改造。他们想要返老还童，变得对衰老和疾病免疫，通常还有一个很长的愿望清单，列出了他们想要改变的方式。我们在基督教中看到了这一点。圣保罗谈到被改造成某种不朽和持久的东西，抛弃这种混乱的生物学物质。但如果我要被改造成某种完全不同的东西，而那不是混乱的生物学，
that isn't whatever 80 years old and full of cancer, what is it that makes that new thing? Me. It sounds like I've been so completely transformed that I have become, if you like, something else. And this is a deep problem with any notion of resurrection. When we come back, if Rejuvenation and Resurrection don't work, where do we turn next? Stephen Cave is a philosopher at the University of Cambridge. He's the author of immortality. He says that as the rejuvenation and resurrection theories run into problems, another story emerges. It says, well, maybe I'm not just this physical body that ages and gets diseased and dies and rot, maybe there's some other kind of
那不是什么80岁且满身癌症的东西，那么是什么让那个新事物成为“我”呢？听起来我已经被彻底改造，以至于我变成了，如果你愿意的话，其他东西。这是任何复活概念的一个深层问题。当我们回来时，如果返老还童和复活都不起作用，我们接下来转向哪里？斯蒂芬·凯夫是剑桥大学的哲学家。他是《永生》的作者。他说，随着返老还童和复活理论遇到问题，另一个故事出现了。它说，好吧，也许我不仅仅是这个会衰老、患病、死亡和腐烂的物理身体，也许还有其他某种
part to me that's immaterial and that doesn't rot. And so this bit of me can maybe survive my biological death. And we see in Christianity, for example, the resurrection story is now bolstered by this idea that there is a soul, and the soul continues to exist to kind of keep the real me going while the body is in this abyss of death, and when the resurrection comes the soul and body are reunited and so the person is whole again. But of course many people are happy to dispense entirely with the messy, failing, aging, wrinkly body and say, no, the soul is all you need, the soul is the real me, and as long
属于我的部分是无形的，不会腐烂。所以我的这一部分也许能在我的生物学死亡后幸存下来。例如，在基督教中，我们看到复活故事现在被这种灵魂观念所支撑，灵魂继续存在，在身体处于死亡深渊时保持真正的“我”继续存在，当复活到来时，灵魂和身体重新结合，所以人又完整了。但当然，许多人乐于完全抛弃混乱、衰竭、衰老、起皱的身体，并说：不，灵魂就是你所需要的，灵魂才是真正的“我”，只要
as that continues, then immortality is mine. Now you write in the book that 71% of Americans believe they have a soul among Brits and Germans, it's closer to 60% in India. It's over 90% in Nigeria. It's close to 100%. In other words, most of the world's 7 billion inhabitants believe they possess something that is besides and outside of their body. Yes.
它继续存在，那么永生就是我的。你在书中写道，71%的美国人相信他们有灵魂，在英国人和德国人中，这一比例接近60%，在印度。在尼日利亚，这一比例超过90%。接近100%。换句话说，世界上70亿居民中的大多数人相信他们拥有某种除了身体之外的东西。是的。
And I think it is a very natural view. After all, we can imagine leaving our bodies behind, and in many traditional religious and mystical practices involve actually cultivating this feeling of entering a kind of dream state or state in which the spirit is able to travel independently of the body. In fact, even dreaming can be seen as being exactly that. And at the same time, it goes back to the mortality paradox that we talked about earlier. The idea that we, even though we know death is a fact, at the same time, we can't imagine ceasing to exist. Well, if I say to you, okay, death is a fact, but only for your body.
我认为这是一种非常自然的观点。毕竟，我们可以想象把身体抛在身后，许多传统的宗教和神秘实践实际上涉及培养这种进入某种梦境状态或精神能够独立于身体旅行的状态的感觉。事实上，即使是做梦也可以被视为正是如此。与此同时，它回到了我们之前谈到的死亡悖论。这种想法是，即使我们知道死亡是一个事实，但与此同时，我们无法想象自己停止存在。好吧，如果我对你说，好吧，死亡是一个事实，但只对你的身体而言。
And you can't imagine ceasing to exist because your soul doesn't cease to exist, and that's the real you. Then we've solved the mortality products very neatly. So it's a kind of, it's a belief that hooks very easily onto our intuitions. What one problem that advocates for the soul narrative have encountered is modern astronomy if you will starting with the Copernican revolution. Because one question that the soul narrative poses is where do souls go? Nowadays asking the question, you know, where do souls go? Seems, and suggesting it might be, you know, over the question, where do souls go, and suggesting it might be over the mountain,
而你无法想象停止存在，因为你的灵魂不会停止存在，而那才是真正的你。那么我们就非常巧妙地解决了死亡悖论。所以这是一种非常容易与我们的直觉挂钩的信仰。灵魂叙事的倡导者遇到的一个问题是现代天文学，如果你愿意的话，从哥白尼革命开始。因为灵魂叙事提出的一个问题是：灵魂去哪儿了？如今问这个问题，你知道，“灵魂去哪儿了？”似乎，并暗示它可能，你知道，关于“灵魂去哪儿了”的问题，并暗示它可能在山上，
sounds a little absurd, like one sort of misunderstood the concept. But actually, for the greater part of human history, it was imagined that souls would be somewhere, but we could point to geographically. It might be under the earth, or it might be on some distant island, or it might be on the moon, but there was a place. You know, when astronauts first went into space, they noted that there were no souls up there, whereas Dante, in the divine comedy, describes in great detail where he thought all the souls were. So it seems that we've been looking for this place. Humans have been theorizing and speculating about this place and looking for it for many centuries, and now we've explored them all
听起来有点荒谬，就像有人误解了这个概念。但实际上，在人类历史的大部分时间里，人们想象灵魂会在某个地方，但我们可以指出地理位置。它可能在地下，或者在某个遥远的岛屿上，或者在月球上，但确实有一个地方。你知道，当宇航员第一次进入太空时，他们注意到上面没有灵魂，而但丁在《神曲》中详细描述了他认为所有灵魂所在的地方。所以看来我们一直在寻找这个地方。人类几个世纪以来一直在对这个地方进行理论化和推测，并寻找它，现在我们已经探索了它们全部，
and peered with our telescopes into the far ends of the universe. We come to the conclusion, well, they're not in this realm. They must be in a different realm. Well, okay, but what exactly does that mean? What does it mean to say that in a different dimension or a different realm? What makes that more than just empty words? Why is that not just an admission of defeat? So in some ways Stephen Buddhism and Hinduism have solutions to these problems. They say that souls don't hang out in some secret place, but they migrate into a new body.
并用望远镜窥视了宇宙的尽头。我们得出的结论是，好吧，它们不在这个领域。它们一定在另一个领域。好吧，但那到底意味着什么？说在另一个维度或另一个领域意味着什么？是什么让它不仅仅是空话？为什么那不仅仅是承认失败？所以在某些方面，斯蒂芬，佛教和印度教对这些问题有解决方案。他们说灵魂不会待在某个秘密地方，而是迁移到一个新的身体里。
In other words, they are reincarnated. You describe how this happens in the book through the story of one little boy whose name was Lamu Dundup. Tell me that story please. So after the 13th Dalai Lama died, it was of course very important to the monks of Tibet to find where his soul had gone,
换句话说，它们转世了。你在书中通过一个小男孩的故事描述了这是如何发生的，他的名字叫拉姆·顿杜普。请告诉我那个故事。在第13世达赖喇嘛圆寂后，西藏的僧侣们当然非常重要地寻找他的灵魂去了哪里，
where it had been reincarnated. And so they traveled the land for many months, looking for children who would have been born about the same time bodies that might have been the right receptacles for this soul, if you like. And so when after months traveling through snowy mountain passes, they came to a house where they heard a boy had been born two years ago, almost exactly the right time. They were very interested. One of the monks got the impression that the boy recognized him.
它在哪里转世了。于是他们走遍了这片土地好几个月，寻找那些大约在同一时间出生的孩子，那些可能是这个灵魂的合适容器的身体。所以当在雪山山口跋涉了几个月后，他们来到了一所房子，听说那里有一个男孩在两年前出生，时间几乎完全吻合。他们非常感兴趣。其中一位僧侣产生了一种印象，觉得那个男孩认出了他。
Excited that this man, the boy, was the reincarnated Dalai Lama, the monks left and came back with a large contingent. the monks left and came back with a large contingent. And so they put a variety of objects out in front of the boy, some of which had belonged to the Dalai Lama, and some of which were just ordinary copies that hadn't. Now, rosaries and walking sticks and prayer drums and the likes. So first the boy picked up the right rosaries and put them around his neck. And then he reached out towards the wrong stick and was about to pick it up, then changed
兴奋于这个男孩就是转世的达赖喇嘛，僧侣们离开了，又带着一大批人回来了。僧侣们离开了，又带着一大批人回来了。于是他们把各种物品放在男孩面前，其中一些属于达赖喇嘛，而另一些只是普通的复制品。念珠、手杖、转经筒之类的。所以男孩先拿起了正确的念珠，戴在脖子上。然后他伸向那根错误的手杖，正要拿起来，然后改变了
his mind and picked up the Dalai Lama stick and all the monks celebrated and cried and believed that found the 14th Dalai Lama. So do you think that the soul narrative, this immortality narrative actually solves the mortality paradox successfully, or are they problems with it? Well, unfortunately you might not be surprised to hear me say that it has problems too. And again, philosophers and theologians have been debating these problems for many thousands of years. Of course, it's easy for most humans to imagine this soul-like thing resides somewhere
主意，拿起了达赖喇嘛的手杖，所有的僧侣都庆祝并哭了，相信找到了第14世达赖喇嘛。那么你认为灵魂叙事，这种永生叙事真的成功地解决了死亡悖论吗，还是它存在问题？好吧，不幸的是，你可能不会惊讶听到我说它也有问题。同样，哲学家和神学家几千年来一直在争论这些问题。当然，大多数人类很容易想象这种类似灵魂的东西存在于
within them, but actually from a philosophical point of view, it's very hard to say what a soul is, where it is, what makes mind different from yours, what it's made from, and so forth. And we are yet to imagine that this immaterial thing, which many known as a scene, that we don't have any very clear or obvious evidence for, actually is the real mean. And philosophers for thousands of years, I say, have been skeptical about this. But now today we have additional reasons to be skeptical. And this is because, you know because for many thousands of years, people have used the idea of the soul to explain the fact that we are thinking conscious beings. You know,
他们体内，但实际上从哲学角度来看，很难说灵魂是什么，它在哪里，什么使我的思想与你的不同，它是由什么构成的，等等。我们还没有想象出这种无形的东西，许多人认为它是看不见的，我们没有任何非常清晰或明显的证据证明它实际上是真正的“我”。几千年来，哲学家们一直对此持怀疑态度。但现在，今天我们有额外的理由持怀疑态度。这是因为，你知道，因为几千年来，人们一直使用灵魂的概念来解释我们是会思考、有意识的生物这一事实。你知道，
it seems mysterious that we humans have intellect and memory and so forth. We don't think rocks or plants have those things. Well, what is it that enables us to have these powers? Well, it's because we have a soul. At least so the story has been for a long time. But now, of course, we understand the brain much better than people previously. And although there are still many mysteries, there is still much we don't understand. Nonetheless, we do know that our mental faculties, like memory and beliefs, even things like a sense of right and wrong, are capacity for emotion. All of these different faculties actually correlate to bits of the brain. We know this from various sources. One of them is brain lesions and brain tumors, and we can see that if a certain chunk of their brain has been destroyed, they can't speak, or they've lost their sense of humor, or they've lost certain memories, or ability to think about the future, and I could see the ways in which as the tumour ate up his brain,
我们人类拥有智力、记忆力等似乎很神秘。我们不认为岩石或植物有这些东西。好吧，是什么使我们拥有这些能力？好吧，是因为我们有一个灵魂。至少这个故事已经流传了很长时间。但现在，当然，我们比以前的人更了解大脑。虽然仍有许多谜团，仍有许多我们不了解的地方。尽管如此，我们确实知道我们的心理功能，如记忆和信仰，甚至像是非观、情感能力等。所有这些不同的功能实际上都与大脑的各个部分相关联。我们从各种来源知道这一点。其中之一是脑损伤和脑肿瘤，我们可以看到，如果他们大脑的某一块被破坏了，他们就无法说话，或者失去了幽默感，或者失去了某些记忆，或者思考未来的能力，我可以看到随着肿瘤吞噬他的大脑，
it was changing his personality. Well, this is a very profound problem for those who think that the real me, the real you, actually is our souls. I mean, if my father had a soul that was the real him, that could preserve his personality and memories and beliefs, etc. on into the afterlife. Why couldn't it do that? Just when part of his brain was being damaged by a brain tumor. So we've looked at three of your immortality narratives, the idea of rejuvenation, the idea of resurrection, and the idea of reincarnation. And this brings us to our last strategy.
它正在改变他的个性。好吧，这对那些认为真正的“我”、真正的“你”实际上是我们的灵魂的人来说，是一个非常深刻的问题。我的意思是，如果我父亲有一个灵魂，那是真正的他，可以保存他的个性和记忆、信仰等进入来世。为什么当他大脑的一部分被脑肿瘤损坏时，它不能做到这一点呢？所以我们看了你的三个永生叙事：返老还童的想法、复活的想法和转世的想法。这引出了我们的最后一个策略。
You introduce the idea in the book by describing some of the exploits of Alexander the Great, recount some of that history to me if you remember it, and tell me what it says about the final immortality narrative. So Alexander the Great was of course one of the great Greek heroes, and he knew that from the start and that was his ambition from the start. So he grew up reading about the exploits of Achilles and the other great Greek heroes and he wanted to become one of them. He wanted to become one of those great Greek heroes. He was self-mythologizing. He wanted to become part of the Pantheon and if we remember the story of Achilles, you know, the great Greek warrior who fought at Troy, when Achilles himself was on the beach at Troy, he faced a choice. He knew because it had been prophesied by his mum who was a goddess,
你在书中通过描述亚历山大大帝的一些事迹来介绍这个想法，如果你记得的话，请复述一些那段历史，并告诉我它说明了关于最后一个永生叙事的什么。所以亚历山大大帝当然是伟大的希腊英雄之一，他从一开始就知道这一点，这也是他从一开始的抱负。所以他从小读着阿喀琉斯和其他伟大希腊英雄的事迹长大，他想成为他们中的一员。他想成为那些伟大的希腊英雄之一。他在自我神话化。他想成为万神殿的一部分，如果我们记得阿喀琉斯的故事，你知道，在特洛伊作战的伟大希腊战士，当阿喀琉斯本人在特洛伊的海滩上时，他面临一个选择。他知道，因为他的妈妈（一位女神）曾预言过，
that he could stay and fight at Troy, and if he did, he'd become a legend, known as the Great Spori of all time time and his story would be told forever. Or he could just go home and be king of a minor kingdom and have children and go hunting and live along an happy life. And of course, he chose to stay and fight and die, and here we are talking about him many thousands of years later. Now, Alexander the Great knew this story inside out, and he even claimed some kind of lineage from Achilles from his mother's side and a few other gods as well, and he set out to beat Achilles himself to become an
他可以留下来在特洛伊战斗，如果他这样做，他将成为一个传奇，被称为有史以来最伟大的战士，他的故事将永远被传颂。或者他可以回家，成为一个小王国的国王，生儿育女，去打猎，过上漫长而幸福的生活。当然，他选择了留下来战斗并死去，而我们在这里谈论他已经是几千年后了。现在，亚历山大大帝对这个故事了如指掌，他甚至声称自己从母亲那边和另外几位神灵那边继承了阿喀琉斯的血统，他出发去打败阿喀琉斯本人，成为一个
even greater legend. And so all of Alexander's exploits, and we see him as a great conquering hero, of course, because he brought Greek civilization to much of Asia. But of course, he killed hundreds of thousands of people. He destroyed whole civilizations. He had women and children put to the sword. I mean, this was a man whose exploits were legendary, but also terrible, incredibly destructive. And they were driven by this one impulse to retain a greater fame than even Achilles. You write in the book that when Alexander left on his conquest, he made sure that his entourage included scribes, historians, and sculptors. He knew it was these, not the priests and alchemists, who were the guardians of eternal life. They were the ones who controlled the realm
更伟大的传奇。所以亚历山大所有的事迹，我们当然视他为伟大的征服英雄，因为他将希腊文明带到了亚洲的大部分地区。但当然，他杀死了成千上万的人。他摧毁了整个文明。他让妇女和儿童死于刀剑之下。我的意思是，这是一个事迹传奇，但也极其可怕、极具破坏性的人。他们被这一个冲动所驱动：保留比阿喀琉斯更伟大的名声。你在书中写道，当亚历山大出发征服时，他确保他的随从包括抄写员、历史学家和雕塑家。他知道是这些人，而不是祭司和炼金术士，才是永生的守护者。他们是控制
of the symbolic, and it is only there that immortality is to be found. That's a really interesting idea that in some ways preserving your name that fame itself was sort of the immortality that Alexander sought. Yeah, so the Greeks made a clear distinction between life, BIOS, which is, as we've talked about, inevitably going to fail. All living things pass away, they rot, their time is brief. They made a distinction between that and the realm of culture, things that can be literally carved in stone, or songs that can be sung, not just by one generation of Bards and Minstress, but for hundreds, thousands of years. And for the Greeks, it was therefore completely clear that immortality wasn't about trying to stay alive in your body, it was fruitless. It wasn't about resurrection
象征领域的人，只有在那里才能找到永生。这是一个非常有趣的想法，在某种程度上，保存你的名字，名声本身就是亚历山大所寻求的永生。是的，所以希腊人对生命（BIOS）做出了明确的区分，正如我们所讨论的，生命必然会失败。所有生物都会消逝，它们会腐烂，它们的时间很短暂。他们将此与文化领域区分开来，那些可以真正刻在石头上的东西，或者不仅可以由一代吟游诗人和歌手传唱，而且可以传唱几百、几千年的歌曲。对于希腊人来说，因此非常清楚，永生不是试图在你的身体里保持活力，那是徒劳的。它也不是关于复活
in this biological body, either. That would just go the same way all over again. It was about trying to carve your name in stone to transfer yourself from this realm of unreliable biology to the realm of culture. It's only there could you find solidity. You know, eternity is a long time and it's not clear that even those who seek fame with the determination that Alexander sought fame really can hold on to that fame for any length of time. I mean, it seems like the search for fame is itself a puny way to overcome death. I think it's very natural for us to think that our civilizations which completely shape our lived reality are somehow forever. But of course
在这个生物身体里。那只会再次走同样的路。它是关于试图将你的名字刻在石头上，将你自己从这个不可靠的生物学领域转移到文化领域。只有在那里你才能找到坚实。你知道，永恒是很长的时间，并不清楚即使是那些以亚历山大寻求名声的决心去寻求名声的人，真的能保持那种名声很长时间。我的意思是，追求名声本身似乎是一种克服死亡的微不足道的方法。我认为我们很容易认为我们的文明，它完全塑造了我们的现实生活，在某种程度上是永恒的。但当然
that isn't the case. The ancient Romans would certainly have thought so the ancient Egyptians, I mean if it was a civilization that lasted for three thousand years, but of course,000 years is not forever. And it's very easy for us now to think that our civilization is so powerful and so sophisticated that surely it will carry on indefinitely. And so if we can attain some kind of fame in this society now, then it will be a kind of forever.
事实并非如此。古罗马人肯定会这么认为，古埃及人也是，我的意思是，如果这是一个持续了三千年的文明，但当然，三千年并不是永远。我们现在很容易认为我们的文明如此强大和复杂，以至于它肯定会无限期地持续下去。所以如果我们现在能在这个社会中获得某种名声，那么它将是一种永恒。
But of course, history teaches us something very different. And maybe all of these millions of photos that were taking ourselves and spreading around the internet in just a couple of generations will find are on files that are now unreadable. There are two underlying problems with all the immortality narratives. First, even though we seek immortality, most of us wouldn't know what to do with it if we had it. As the novelist Susan Earth's writes, millions long for immortality who wouldn't know what to do with it if we had it. As the novelist Susan Earthschrides, millions long for immortality,
但当然，历史教给我们的是非常不同的东西。也许我们正在为自己拍摄并传播到互联网上的这数百万张照片，在短短几代人之后，我们会发现它们是在现在无法读取的文件上。所有永生叙事都有两个潜在的问题。首先，即使我们寻求永生，如果我们真的拥有它，我们大多数人也不知道该怎么办。正如小说家苏珊·厄斯所写，数以百万计的人渴望永生，却不知道如果拥有它该怎么办。正如小说家苏珊·厄斯所写，数以百万计的人渴望永生，
who don't know what to do with themselves on a rainy Sunday afternoon. Because of course it's not eternity that we're seeking. What we want is just to not die. I don't want to die today. I don't want to don't think I want to die tomorrow. But of course if you never die today or tomorrow, then you end up living forever, even if that wasn't really what you wanted. And when we try to imagine forever, the mind boggles.
却不知道在雨后的周日下午该拿自己怎么办。因为当然，我们寻求的不是永恒。我们想要的只是不死亡。我今天不想死。我不想，不认为我想明天死。但当然，如果你今天或明天永远不死，那么你最终会永远活下去，即使那并不是你真正想要的。当我们试图想象永恒时，大脑会感到困惑。
The mind just gives up and runs. We have no way of grasping something like eternity. And those who have speculated about it and really tried to think it through tend to come to the conclusion pretty quickly that it's going to be boring and miserable. It's a wonderful story that Hogi Luis Borges tells in his short story, The Immortal. It's about a Roman centurion who seeks a river that cleanses men of death. And in his travels he finally comes to this land of the troglodytes, these people who just lie in shallow pit staring at the sky. One of them has been still for so long a bird is nesting on his chest.
大脑只是放弃并逃跑了。我们无法掌握像永恒这样的东西。那些推测过它并真正试图想通它的人，往往很快得出结论，它将是无聊和悲惨的。豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯在他的短篇小说《永生》中讲述了一个精彩的故事。这是一个关于一名罗马百夫长寻找一条能洗去人类死亡的河流的故事。在他的旅途中，他最终来到了这个穴居人的土地，这些人只是躺在浅坑里盯着天空。其中一个人已经静止了太久，一只鸟在他的胸口筑巢。
And Bessenturian wakes these people and says, you know, who are you? He discovers that they are the immortals. And one of them is Homer, who wrote the Iliad in the Odyssey. And he says, well, isn't that amazing? Aren't you proud of your fantastic achievements? Why are you lying here? It was picked. And Homer says, but don't you see? It's impossible not to write the Odyssey,
贝森图里安唤醒了这些人，问道：你们是谁？他发现他们是不朽者。其中一人是荷马，他写了《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》。他说，这难道不令人惊叹吗？难道你不为自己辉煌的成就感到自豪吗？为什么你躺在这里？这被选中了。荷马说，但你没看出来吗？如果你永生，你不可能不写《奥德赛》至少一次。
at least once, if you live forever. And so the idea is, if we all live forever, we all end up doing everything we have every possible experience, multiple times, everything starts to blend into one, everything becomes meaningless. Stephen says, there is a second mistake in all the immortality narratives. They see death as a problem to be solved. They take the mortality paradox at face value, if you like, but they say death is terrifying on the one hand,
因此，这个想法是，如果我们都永生，我们最终都会做所有事情，经历所有可能的体验，经历多次，一切开始融合为一，一切都变得毫无意义。斯蒂芬说，所有关于永生的叙事中都有第二个错误。他们把死亡视为一个需要解决的问题。他们从字面上接受了死亡悖论，如果你愿意的话，但他们说死亡一方面是可怕的，
and it's impossible to imagine not being on the other. And so we have to try to reconcile these by not dying and keeping going indefinitely. But actually we can really instead question the assumptions behind the mortality paradox. Well, even though it's hard to imagine not existing, that doesn't mean we won't cease to exist. Now this is a difficult thought to grapple with and I think the first person who really did grapple with it, at least in recorded history, was the Greek philosopher Epicurus, who said, when I am here, death is not, and when death is here, I am not. And therefore, I don't have to worry about dying. So he meant that exactly because death is ceasing to exist, we don't need to think about what might come
另一方面，想象不存在是不可能的。所以我们必须尝试通过不死和无限期地继续下去来调和这些。但实际上，我们可以质疑死亡悖论背后的假设。嗯，即使很难想象不存在，但这并不意味着我们不会停止存在。这是一个难以处理的想法，我认为第一个真正处理它的人，至少在有记载的历史中，是希腊哲学家伊壁鸠鲁，他说，当我在时，死亡不在，当死亡在时，我不在。因此，我不必担心死亡。所以他的意思是，正是因为死亡是停止存在，我们不需要考虑之后可能会发生什么，
after, we don't need to think about heaven or hell, or keeping it going indefinitely, we won't be around to regret not being around. Now, because of the mortality paradox, because we cannot imagine ceasing to exist, it's very, very hard to accept this. And of course, Epicurus believed you had to kind of repeat it to yourself and as a mantra to truly live according to this insight and so be free of the fear of death. the fear of death. For lots of our Stephen Cave works at the University of Cambridge, he is the author of the book Immortality, The Quest to Live Forever, and How it Drives Civilization.
我们不需要考虑天堂或地狱，或者无限期地继续下去，我们不会因为不存在而感到遗憾。现在，由于死亡悖论，因为我们无法想象停止存在，所以很难接受这一点。当然，伊壁鸠鲁认为你必须把它当作咒语重复给自己听，才能真正按照这个洞察力生活，从而摆脱对死亡的恐惧。对许多人来说，斯蒂芬·凯夫在剑桥大学工作，他是《永生：追求永生以及它如何驱动文明》一书的作者。
Stephen, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Breasts. Thank you, it's my pleasure. This week's show was produced by Laura Corral, and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Paatscha, Raina Cohen and Thomas Liu. Our aunts' song Hero this week is Melissa Marquis. Melissa works on our ops desk at NPR. She helps coordinate studio space for various teams and shows. Melissa is the walking definition of an Unsung Hero.
斯蒂芬，感谢你今天加入我的Hidden Brain节目。谢谢，这是我的荣幸。本周的节目由劳拉·科拉尔制作，塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括帕查、雷娜·科恩和托马斯·刘。我们本周的无名英雄是梅丽莎·马奎斯。梅丽莎在NPR的运营部门工作。她帮助协调各个团队和节目的演播室空间。梅丽莎是无名英雄的活生生的定义。
Always ready to help? Always thinking about what's best for the organization. Like so many unsung heroes we recognized on this show, we simply couldn't do what we do without her. Thanks Melissa. If this episode spoke to you in some way, please remember to share it with someone who isn't currently listening to Hidden Brain. If the person is new to podcasting, please take a moment to show
总是乐于助人？总是考虑什么对组织最好。就像我们在节目中认可的许多无名英雄一样，没有她，我们根本无法完成我们的工作。谢谢你，梅丽莎。如果这一集以某种方式触动了你，请记得把它分享给那些目前没有收听Hidden Brain的人。如果对方是播客新手，请花点时间向他们展示
them how easy it is to subscribe. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. Ah! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
订阅是多么容易。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。啊！这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。